Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schön den guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus sicher ich habe was
Verrücktes vor ich wollte dich heute mal
zum Thema
Pioniergeist befragen Erika Eroberer
Erfinder der hat nämlich noch eine
interessante Zahl auf die bin ich jetzt
schon mehrfach gestoßen gelesen die Zahl
der deutschen Patentanmeldungen ist in
letzter Zeit rückläufig sechs fast
sieben Prozent weniger als im Jahr davor
gleichzeitig in China 23% + und wir
liegen aber immer noch vor China oder in
absoluten Zahlen meinst du jetzt ja
möglicherweise aber da passiert
26000 Patente 2022 ja okay und die
Chinesen aber glaube ich schon ein Stück
weniger aber also wir sind Nummer zwei
in der Welt ja hinter den USA und dann
kommen Japan China und Frankreich aber
du hast natürlich völlig recht ne wir
schwächeln und die Chinesen holen auf ja
mir geht's weißt du ich
ist auch dass die die
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler streiten sich
darüber und sagen naja komm komm komm
man kann ja mit die Frage ob ein Land
prosperiert und ob es irgendwie nach
vorne geht die kann man jetzt nun
wirklich nicht nur in der Zahl der
Patente anmelden und das ist bestimmt
ablesen und das ist bestimmt auch
richtig richtig aber das ist eine
interessante genau und dann bin ich
gestolpert über ein Interview von Ulrich
Walter bist du dem schon mal begegnet
erstaunlicherweise nicht obwohl er auch
viele Vorträge hält ja super viel über
ihn erzählt worden ja der ist großartig
der kann Dir stundenlang darüber
erzählen wie Stuhlgang im All
funktioniert und so weiter und nur bei
ihm ist das niemals eklig sondern immer
unfassbar interessant und du willst
immer mehr davon wissen wer macht das
hast Du Angelegenheit
ja ja ja ja ja wirklich ein ganz
brillanter Erzähler Professor auch und
so weiter Physiker und es gibt wenige
Menschen die die so wunderbar irgendwie
kompliziert ist der Physik so erklären
können dass du das Gefühl hast du
verstehst es also mit anderen Worten
Ulrich Walter hat diese
dir Dinge zu erzählen die unfassbar
kompliziert sind und dir trotzdem das
gute Gefühl zu geben
total an dem Block bist genau genau und
dafür liebe ich ihn weil
das das hat sowas empathisch ist weißt
du sowas menschenfreundliches und Ulrich
Walter sagte dieser Tag in einem
Interview uns fehlt mittlerweile der
Pioniergeist und dann Henry Ford wenn
ich die Menschen gefragt hätte was Sie
wollen ja der berühmte Autobauer dann
hätten sie gesagt wir wollen schnellere
Pferde an Autos hat keiner gedacht ja
und trotzdem fahren wir jetzt alle mit
dem Auto ja das heißt irgendwann mal und
immer wieder an bestimmten Punkten
unserer Geschichte hat es Menschen
gegeben die weitergedacht haben die mehr
wollten die große Risiken eingegangen
sind also sozusagen das das krasse der
krasse gegen Entwurf zu unserer
Vollkasko Gesellschaft der aber alles
hauptsache immer sicher und kann bloß
nichts passieren sondern große Wagen ist
ja eingegangen sind und am finde die
Menschen wirklich weitergebracht haben
ja wer sind die Menschen die dich
diesbezüglich inspiriert haben na gut
das ist schon ein bisschen eher so was
in meine Richtung geht also es war nicht
so häufig die Naturwissenschaftler als
eben langer Leute die in der Philosophie
die Bahn brechen das geleistet haben
aber was ich interessant finde ist ja
weißt du der der Pioniergeist einer
Gesellschaft ist ablesbar an den
pionierhelden und ich meine in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik wir haben
ja sowieso nicht mehr viele Helden na
wer ist denn ein deutscher Held der
nicht von den Medien inzwischen
auseinander genommen wäre
wahrscheinlich der größte lebende
Deutsche Held das stimmt ja ja ja aber
viele andere Helden also wir haben die
Jan Ullrichs und die Boris Beckers und
die Beckenbauers und so weiter so unsere
Sporthelden die wir haben die sind
eigentlich mehr oder weniger inzwischen
aufgelöst und zertrümmert und es sind
eigentlich nicht so viele Helden da und
vor allem pionierhelden haben wir ja
eigentlich gar keine
also Leute die so heute in der Forschung
waren Brechen des geleistet haben oder
die Menschheit nach vorne gebracht
hätten oder so die jetzt jeder kennt ja
und wo Kinder sagen oh wie der will dich
werden ja also das ist ja wichtig und
ich dir so in USA ist das glaube ich
anders also die die Heldenverehrung ist
da größer früher im Ostblock war die ja
massiv ne die Kosmonauten und die
Sporthelden die da vergöttert wurden und
wir leben ja in so einer postheroischen
Gesellschaft also eigentlich will ja
keiner mehr in Held werden ich denke so
dieses Pioniergeist das finden wir
irgendwie im Prinzip ja ganz toll ne
aber das setzt natürlich auch also viele
Pioniere werden in hungrigen
Gesellschaften geboren und wir sind
keine besonders hungrige Gesellschaft es
ist auch ziemlich schwierig sie
künstlich wieder hungrig zu machen und
sie quasi auf die Idee zu setzen damit
sie wieder hungrig wird wenn man sich so
die Zeitalter anguckt na wo die
Seefahrer in die Welt aufgebrochen
wurden sind oder so jemand wie Kolumbus
der ja eine der ja irgendeine verkracht
der Existenz war der hatte durch durch
durch seine Überfahrt nur zu gewinnen ja
und nichts zu verlieren und das gibt es
relativ häufig und es gibt natürlich
auch so andere verrückte Pioniere
Milliardäre oder so ne die die wie
Howard use oder so aber eigentlich ist
irgendein klassisches Muster für für
Pionierleistung gerade so bei den
Entdeckern oder bei den Seefahrern oder
so dass sie nicht viel zu verlieren
hatten aber wahnsinnig viel zu gewinnen
wenn das aufgehen würde also das war so
ein bisschen das Lotto spielen der
damaligen Zeit ein Kolumbus hatte ja
bekanntermaßen nicht vor Amerika zu
entdecken und hat auch nicht darauf
gerettet das ist Amerika gibt er hatte
das Glück dass Amerika dazwischen liegt
also sonst wären die irgendwo im Pazifik
zu Grunde gegangen weil die viel zu
wenig Proviant und Wasser an Bord hat
und und und und Kolumbus hatte für dich
spinnerte Vorstellung davon wie klein
die Kugel ist die sich Erde nennt
er hatte da einen italienischen
Kartografen vertraut und diese
Berechnung waren alle falsch und das
Spannende an der kolumbusgeschichte ist
ja ist ja die runter das Mathematiker ne
das Gremium des Königs ja dass darüber
befinden sollte ob Kolumbus Schiffe zur
Verfügung gestellt kriegt um den Seeweg
nach Indien den den Best Weg nach Indien
zu finden die wussten auch dass die Erde
eine Kugel ist ja das hat man nicht an
die große Glocke gehängt weil das eine
ungünstig war stand in der Bibel ja ein
bisschen anders drin aber natürlich
wussten die das die wussten aber auch
dass der Weg zu lang ist dass das nicht
klappt
und das haben sie eben diese Krücken von
Schiffe gegeben also wirklich so die
drei rammsteine ja also die Santa Maria
und die Nina und so weiter die
eigentlich keiner braucht sonst
weil die ging davon aus das geht zu 99%
schief und wie gesagt hätte Amerika
nicht dazwischen genau wäre es schief
gegangen das wäre genau ja und zwar zu
100 %. ja ich denke gerade die ganze
Zeit darüber nach weißt du wer für mich
z.B ein deutscher Held ist kennt kaum
einer Ingmar her kennst du den nee was
läuft in deutscher Biologe war glaube
ich zweimal bei mir in der Sendung die
Geschichte von Ingwer her hat mich
wahnsinnig fasziniert ist der Gründer
von cure Weg ja und immer höher war
derjenige der als erste angefangen hat
sozusagen mit messenger RNA zu
experimentieren okay und er hat mir die
Geschichte erzählt wie er irgendwann
Ende der 90er Jahre
steht in in Tübingen in seinem Labor und
es regnet draußen das ist das so ein
halb dunkler Abend und der stellt
plötzlich fest das was die ganze Zeit
erzählt wurde nämlich das das wahnsinnig
flüchtig ist und dass das alles sofort
zerfällt und deswegen nicht funktioniert
ja im Gegensatz zu anderen Impfstoffen
zu den konventionellen Impfstoffen ist
nicht so sondern hat nachgewiesen dass
das viel stabiler ist als ursprünglich
gedacht und hat das dann weiter
getrieben und eigentlich geht dann
später die die Impfung die Messenger
rna-impfung die dann bei Corona ja so
eine große Rolle gespielt hat ja auch
nicht unumstritten aber das geht alles
auf ihn zurück und in Wahrheit ist das
ganze Thema eben keine Sache die
irgendwann 2020 oder 21
entwickelt wurde sondern ihn Wahrheit
hat er ganz junge immer höher in Ende
der 90er in Tübingen dafür die
entscheidende Grundlagenforschung
gemacht und er hat mir davon erzählt wie
der Moment war als er plötzlich merkte
warte mal ich hier bin ich einer Sache
auf der Spur sondern
Professor sagte mal lass das Verkehr
heute nicht an der Energie damit das
wird niemals funktionieren und der hat
dann als erster nachgewiesen dass es
funktioniert und ich habe mal nach den
nach dem Unterschied gefragt und da
meinte er weißt du stell dir vor ich
bringe sozusagen das was dann das
Immunsystem triggert das musst du ja in
die Zelle reinbringen ja die Information
und eine klassische konventionelle
Impfung musst du dir vorstellen wie ein
Tresor und da rein packst du die
Information und das geht dann in diese
Zelle rein und bis das alles dann
irgendwann verstopft wechselt ist
verschwunden ist aus der Zelle raus ist
auch dieser Tresor das dauert sehr sehr
lange das kann man lange nachweisen und
dann liegt das ja wirklich sozusagen an
unserer DNA liegt das ja alles wirklich
dran ja also in unserer Zelle das was
wir wirklich sind unheimlich wenn du
anfängst wirklich darüber nachzudenken
ja also vermischt sich das
möglicherweise was passiert dann damit
uns und so weiter daher kommen ja auch
glaube ich instinktiv die Vorbehalte
vieler Leute auch gegen Impfungen und er
sagte das was ich gemacht habe ist etwas
völlig anderes was ich gemacht habe war
ich nehme diese Information packe sie in
einen kleinen Briefumschlag und dann
bringe ich es in die Zelle rein und
alles das löst sich nach wenigen Stunden
oder manchmal Tagen löst sich das auf
und ist nicht anders genau das ist
sozusagen das revolutionäre an dieser
Geschichte und dann hat er mir noch
großartige Geschichte erzählt wie er
dann anfing das dann wirklich als
Startup weiterzuentwickeln hat dann
Leute gewonnen wie wie Dietmar Haupt z.B
der war einer der großen Geldgeber ganz
am Anfang und dann erzählt er mir von
einer Reise nach Paris
und er sollte dort präsentieren ein
großer amerikanischer Investor der Name
dieses Investors Bill Gates
und dann sagte wie war das dann also wie
wie läuft das ab welche Hotelsuite war
das wo ist das passiert und er sagte
völlig völlig falsch es war ein Hotel
aber weil Bill Gates unter keinen
Umständen irgendwie einen großen Wirbel
um seine Person wollte haben uns
getroffen im Heizungskeller dieses
Hotels
da hat der präsentiert völlig verrückt
und Bill Gates kam rein und er hatte
sehr viele Folien und Charts vorbereitet
und nach
Folie 15 vorher guckte Bill Gates sehr
gelangweilt irgendwo nach links und
rechts und plötzlich bei Folie 15 16
hakt der einen und sagt zeigt noch mal
was ist das hier genau und lässt sich
das erklären und hat dann wenig später
die Zusage für viele viele Millionen
Dollar so liegt die Geschichte
ist total interessant und das ist ein
moderner Held das die die Pointe eine
sehr ich finde bittere Pointe ist als
Corona dann kam und und das war ja das
was er auch immer im Kopf hatte ihm war
immer klar wir könnten irgendwann mit
einem solchen Virus zu tun haben und das
könnte ein Problem werden und dann könnt
ihr diese Technik wichtig werden für uns
als das dann kam erleidet er einen
schweren Schlaganfall
und ist monatelang im Koma und als er
wach wird ist das alles längst im Gange
das heißt der der fällt ins Koma zu
einem Zeitpunkt an dem noch nicht so
richtig klar ist was da passiert und als
er wieder wach wird ist die Welt eine
andere Geschichte aus Märchenbuch
gut ja dem geht's wieder gut und und der
der das ist ein ganz faszinierender
bescheidener netter Mann ja lebt den
Tübingen also und es ist ein es ist ein
Held ja entspannter
Pionier und Belohnung genau
Schnittstellen zusammen richtig also wie
groß ist die Zahl der Pioniere ohne
Belohnung also für mich die die die
große tragische pioniergeschichte ist
die von Ignaz semmelweiss also in Ungarn
in Österreich Ungarn Mediziner der in
Wien im Krankenhaus ist und dort werden
gleichzeitig die Frauen entbunden und
damals lag irgendwie die
Kindersterblichkeit in den ersten Tagen
bei 13 Prozent also sehr hoch im
Krankenhaus eben nicht zu Hause und so
weiter sondern im Krankenhaus wo also
jetzt die Profis sich darum kümmern wir
reden Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
und damals haben die Ärzte die die
Kinder entbunden hat auch andere
Aufgaben gehabt das waren also nicht
alle spezialisiert auf Geburtshilfe
sondern die Macht noch andere Sachen zum
Beispiel hielten die dann Stunde vorher
Vorlesungen in der Pathologie und
erklärten den Studenten die Leichen und
schnibbeln die auf und
Ignaz war der erste der ein Zusammenhang
gestiftet hat zwischen dem sogenannten
kindbett-fieber also neben dem Tod ja
der der Kinder oft auch Mütter auf der
einen Seite und der Tätigkeit der Ärzte
auf der anderen Seite ja indem er
nämlich dachte okay die bringen das
Leichen Gift ja mit und er regt er an ob
man sich nicht die Hände waschen sollte
in so einem kalkhaltigen Wasser
und das haben natürlich die Ärzte
verweigert und haben gesagt wir haben
das schon immer so gemacht und von dir
Greenhorn lassen wir jetzt hier
Assistenzarzt dass wir uns jetzt nicht
erklären was wir zu tun haben
tatsächlich wurden dann aber doch
Versuche gemacht und es stellte sich
fest man dies man konnte die die Gefahr
wenn man sich die Hände wusch und zwar
immer vorher wusch ja irgendwann kriegt
er selber weiß auch raus das ist nicht
nur das Leichen Gift jeder Mensch
springt Keime da rein jede Begegnung
jede medizinische Untersuchung das war
also immer sich die Hände waschen sollte
weil ich vergessen das Prinzip des Hände
Waschens ja um die Hände Stil zu kriegen
und keine abzutöten war nicht bekannt
also niemand wusch sich überhaupt die
Hände doch der Arbeiter der nach Hause
kam oder der Bauer nach der fällt
Arbeiten nicht ja also wenn sich die
Hände wuscheln dann weil sie nicht schön
Aussagen aber nicht weil Angst hat er
bringt Keime mit er hatte als erste
diesen Zusammenhang erkannt aber das
bedeutet auch dass diese Ärzte die
vorher immer in die Pathologie gegangen
waren dass die Hunderte oder Tausende
von Menschen leben auf dem Gewissen
hatten weil sie sich vorhin nicht die
Hände gewaschen hatten und das die
natürlich nicht einsehen
das heißt man hat ihn also mit
ziemlichem schimpf- und Schande da
weggejagt dann war er noch an einem
anderen krankenhausprofessor aber diese
Leistung von ihm die ist nicht anerkannt
worden und dieses regelmäßige
händewaschen ist auch nicht eingeführt
worden das heißt er sah also sehenden
Auges wie all die Menschen starben ja
weil sein Prinzip was er entdeckt hatte
und was völlig richtig war nicht
angewendet wurde einfach weil diejenigen
die das schon immer gemacht hatten kein
schlechtes Gewissen haben wollten also
haben sie lieber bestritten dass dieser
medizinische Zusammenhang besteht als
die Praxis zu ändern und er kriegt er
darüber Depressionen und ist dann von
Kollegen Zwangs eingewiesen worden in
einer ihren Anstalt und in dieser
Irrenanstalt hatte also immer wieder
versucht begreiflich zu machen dass
nicht ihr irre ist ja sondern dass das
quasi Intrige ist sie in der hingebracht
hat das heißt er wurde aufsässig und ist
dann von den Wörtern dieser Irrenanstalt
im Gefängnishof zu Tode geprügelt worden
bitter als eine unglaublich tragische
traurige Geschichte und wenn man sich
überlegt wie viele Leben hat wohl die
Leistung von ihnen hat Semmel weiß dass
er dann post mortem nach seinem Tod ist
das ein wissenschaftliches allgemein gut
geworden ist dadurch dass man also
vernünftige Hygiene eingeführt hat ja
mit Hände waschen und sterilisieren und
was weiß ich überhaupt erst alles was
man vorher nicht kannte ich meine das
sind ja Millionen und Arme Millionen
leben die dieser Mann nach seinem Tode
noch quasi gerettet hat also Lebzeiten
ja als Spinner
bekämpft nicht ernst genommen und so
weiter und dieses Schicksal hatten ja
viele Pioniere ja du weißt an wen ich
gerade denke an Nicolas Tesla Nicolas
Tesla ist auch so eine Geschichte das
stimmt Nicolas Tesla serbisch der dann
irgendwann in den 1880er Jahren nach New
York ausgewandert ist und dann dort
trifft auf Thomas Edison er hat den
Erfinder der Glühbirne der anders als
Tesla total
Erwachsener Geschäftsmann Dagobert Duck
ja
genau und und die Welt steht heute aber
also Edison war total von Gleichstrom
überzeugt dass du noch angefangen in New
York so Kraftwerke zu bauen und wollte
die ganze Stadt weil man das eben nicht
weit transportieren kann mit so mit so
kleinen lokalen Kraftwerken zu pflastern
ja um um seinen Strom zu verkaufen und
und tesla hat ihm die ganze Zeit erklärt
mir pass auf das kann man ganz anders
machen Bau das Kraftwerk irgendwo weit
draußen und mache es dann mit
Wechselstrom und obwohl heute die ganze
Welt Wechselstrom nutzt ist dieses
selbstlose Genie Tesla 1943 völlig
verarmt gestorben
ist bitter ja das gibt es dort also ich
glaube diese diese Geschichten sind
sogar häufiger als die
Erfolgsgeschichten nur sind wenn wir
jetzt Elon Musk sich nicht auf Tesla
Berufen hätte kaum noch jemand wüsste
mit Ausnahme von Spezialisten wer Tesla
eigentlich gewesen ist ja genau ich
glaube die Welt ist voll davon also ich
weiß zum Beispiel dass eines der ganz
großen Probleme der Menschheit Bestand
mal darin dass man die Längen gerade
nicht bestimmen konnte also man man die
breiten gerade zu bestimmen war
offensichtlich einfach aber die Längen
gerade wenn man jetzt auch See war
rauszukriegen wie der Längengrad war das
war ein riesiges ungelöstes Problem und
dann warte irgendwie ein London und
Akademie oder so auch mal achtjährigen
jetzt 18 das 19 Jahrhundert einen Preis
ausgesetzt wäre also ganz ganz genau
diese Längen gerade bestimmen damit man
natürlich immer angeben kann auch sehen
ne und auch weiß genau wo man ist Tobias
Meyer der der dieses Rätsel gelöst hat
und mit Hilfe einer Uhr ein System
erfunden hat so genauen Längengrad
Bestimmung dass wie das Preisgeld
gekriegt hat das war damals so
unvorstellbare Summe also nach über 100
Millionen nach unserer heutigen
Vorstellung so wichtig war diese
längengradfrage und dann haben sie ihn
versucht nachzuweisen dass das System
aber nur zu 99,9% verlässt nicht ist
irgend so eine Mist ja und Tobias Meyer
kennt bis auf ein paar Gelehrte
eigentlich heute überhaupt niemand mehr
ja und der hat einen bahnbrechende
Leistung für die Schifffahrt und damit
für den Welthandel Krach geleistet ja
und dieser Mann ist stets um seine
Anerkennung betrogen worden und das Geld
hat er auch nicht gekriegt
Pioniergeist ne ich habe ja immer das
Gefühl ich habe Pioniere das ist das so
etwas wahnsinnig amerikanisches die die
irgendwo also alle großen Pioniere auch
bis heute sind sind eigentlich gefühlt
Amerikaner wir haben gerade festgestellt
es ist nicht so ja aber das gehört so
sehr zu Identität und zum
Selbstverständnis dieses Landes klar
das Land besiedelt haben genau also
dadurch dass man den Indianer das Land
geklaut hat und quasi so getan hat als
wäre dieses Land überhaupt erstmal
entdeckt worden durch klauen das ist ja
sozusagen von Anfang an
dieses dass man das Land der Pioniere
ist und das war ja auch immer die Rede
von den New frontier ja das ist immer
die Grenze die man immer weiter
verschiebt und weiter verschiebt und
weiter verschiebt und das ist quasi Uhr
amerikanische DM total wenn du auch
dieses dieses Wort frontier das ist
etwas das dir immer unterkommt wenn du
in Amerika unterwegs bist und wenn du
z.B dann Richtung Alaska gehst oder so
dann ist es der Last frontiert die die
letzte Grenze ja die sowas sowas mytisch
ist und da da fahren wir jetzt hin und
da gehen wir jetzt hin zu dieses
aufbrechen in die Terrain kogniter ja
das unbekannte Land und ich meine wenn
man sich klar macht die die ersten
Siedler 18 ist 19 Jahrhundert die haben
ein Wahrheit nur so ein ganz schmalen
Streifen entlang der amerikanischen
Ostküste
selber sie posten und New York und so
weiter sind bewohnt ja und dahinter
liegt sozusagen genau das diese dieses
unbekannte dieses gefährliche Land
Klammer auf der war schon jemand aber
man tat so als als wäre man jetzt der
erste ja Gott hatte es aber den Leuten
die da lebt nicht geschenkt ja weil die
Leute haben ja wie John Lock damals
sagte ich hatte das ja schon mal einen
anderen Folge zitiert Ihren Boden die
haben den Boden ja nicht verkackt und
sich damit gegen Gott versündigt der ja
will dass man sich die Erde untertan
macht wer nur mit seinen Zelten darüber
zieht ja der hat kein Recht Anrecht
darauf das Land auch zu besitzen sondern
nur der der Ackerbau und Viehzucht
betreibt und mit der Legitimation konnte
man dann gegen die Uwe Bevölkerung
vorgehen aber diese pioniergeschichte
ist wichtig ja ich dachte jetzt gerade
als du von Amerika für die Russen war
das auch immer wichtig
also interessanterweise wenn man
überlegt diese ganze Kosmonauten
Mythologie die ist in der Sowjetunion
gegeben hat der erste Mensch im All und
erste rund im All und und die erste
kreisung und so weiter also diese diese
Heldentaten diese Pioniertaten auf
Forschungsgebiet oder oder Eroberung des
Weltraums also da spielte dieses
pioniersein auch eine große Rolle vor
allem wenn man mal überlegt wie viel
Geld die Russen also die Sowjets damals
in ihr Raumfahrtprogramm rein investiert
haben also wenn man diese ganzen
mondraketen die die gebaut haben die nie
gezündet haben die zum Teil bis 250 m
groß waren und das in das in einer
Volkswirtschaft ja die auf dem letzten
Loch ist anders als in den USA die ja
auch von ihren Raumfahrtprogramm
wirtschaftlich enorm profitiert haben
oder viele Erfindungen gemacht wurden
und so ne also die die Sowjetunion hat
diesen Pioniergeist sehr sehr teuer
bezahlt also der Durchschnittsbürger hat
den sehr teuer bezahlt und danach immer
so propagandistisch genutzt diesen
Wettlauf ja das sollte der natürlich
klar so ein Quatsch die Frage wäre als
erster erster den den grundbetritt
sollte irgendetwas darüber aussagen
welches das bessere und gerechtere
System ist wenn sich eine völlig völlig
unsinnige Verkettung ja von also der
depressiv sollte gleichzeitig das System
heiligen ja ja ich ich muss immer an
diesen an diesen beiden bei dieser
Propaganda und bei diesem Bett laufen
muss ich mal diesen alten Witz denken
kennst du wahrscheinlich auch Christoph
von Nixen machen einen Wettlauf ja und
ähm nächsten gewinnt und Kunststoff
jetzt weiter ja und die amerikanische
Propaganda macht daraus nichts ein
großartiger erster und Kunststoff
letzter ja und die russische Propaganda
macht daraus raus Christoph großartiger
zweiter nächsten Vorletzter ja das ist
so ja ja
großartig immer sehr weil er sehr gut
Propaganda erklärt ja wie das wie das
funktioniert
aber tatsächlich dieser dieser
pioniergedanke in den USA die dieser
Mythos sozusagen vom vom wilden vom
unbegrenzten Land ja diese weißen Männer
die dabei eine große Rolle spielen wo es
interessanterweise wusste ich auch nicht
es waren zum ganz großen Teil Frauen ne
die das Land gerodet haben die Bäume
gefällt haben die Häuser richtig gebaut
haben das war nicht die Männer die die
Männer waren sozusagen das war der
vornehmetall waren mit der Eroberung
beschäftigt aber ohne die Frauen dieser
Pioniergeist und diese Pionier
Leistungen die amerikanischen völlig
undenkbar stellt sich das Schicksal der
Frauen ja viel brutaler vor also wenn du
dich gleichzeitig Kinder kriegst um die
Kinder kümmern musst ja die Familie
wirtschaftlich durchbringen muss und so
weiter dagegen ist ja diese andere
Auftrag eine übersichtliche Leistung im
Vergleich zu diesem richtig
wahnsinnig komplexen und sehen und
fordern im Leben was man als Mutter
hatte in einer Pioniere Gesellschaft
heute diese diese Zeit und diese Idee
das prägt die Amerikaner bis heute und
das ist auch so tief in den drin das
merkt man immer und ich glaube das ist
auch eine der Gründe warum die gerade
also diese ganze Startup Kultur und so
weiter das ist etwas so uramerikanisch
auch in die immer wieder also durch neue
pioniert haben ist absolut wichtig um
die Geschichte vom American Dream ja wie
brüchig auch immer sie ist am Leben zu
erhalten ja ich habe vor einiger Zeit
eine Zahl gelesen ich glaube das stimmt
so gar nicht aber aber trotzdem in der
Tendenz glaube ich gibt es eine Richtung
vor neuen der zehn reichsten Amerikaner
sind Gründer und 9 der 10 reichsten
Deutschen sind Erben ja das und das
macht sozusagen klar wurde der
Unterschied liegt genau welche
kollektive Mentalität da dahinter ist ja
das stimmt ich würde mit dir gerne mal
über einen Helden reden wo ich ganz
sicher bin dass der bei dir auf positive
Resonanz ja ich bin bei Markus du bist
ja du bist ja der Mensch für die Pole ja
ja und die die Geschichte der Pole hat
mich auch immer interessiert und
fasziniert wahrscheinlich weil es eines
der letzten großen entdeckungsabenteuer
war gab ne es war ja eigentlich alles
bekannt zu dem Zeitpunkt also es gab
vielleicht noch ein paar Gegend im
Inneren von Neuguinea oder der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik die noch
nicht so bekannt waren aber es bestand
ja also ich glaube die die Pole sind ja
aus der Verzweiflung heraus erforscht
worden dass der Rest inzwischen bekannt
war ja also keine anderen Reisen mehr
machen das ausgerechnet das war übrig
geblieben und da gab es auch nach der
damaligen Vorstellung wirtschaftlich
nichts zu holen heute sehen wir das
anders aber damals war das eigentlich
nur noch das übrig geblieben total es
ging um und Ehre ja also gerade für die
Norweger
hatten sich von den Schweden gerade
getrennt von wirtschaftlichen Nationen
als Nation sonst er brauchten die einen
Gründungsmythos ja eine große Idee ich
glaube immer nachdem die Pole entdeckt
wurden wurde der Sport wichtig
weil eigentlich ist das der Übergang zum
Sport weil das eigentlich aus
sportlichem Ehrgeiz ist man zu dem Polen
aufgebrochen zu den anderen Sachen ich
meine diese ganzen Expeditionen um die
Welt ne von Kolumbus Magellan und so
Vasco da Gama da ging es um handfeste
Interessen man wollte man das erobern
wollte man Handeltreiben und sich was
unter Nagel reißen und so aber die Pole
wollte man sich ja nicht ernsthaft unter
Nagel reißen also kann man Fähnchen
reinmachen wie auf dem Mond genau aber
es ist ja so eine rein sportliche
Angelegenheit im Grunde genommen und
wenn man sich diese Geschichte mal weil
ich habe das so mit dem roten Ohren da
in meinem Erdkundebuch mir angeguckt so
weißt du Schuljahr haben wir das gemacht
dieses blaue Erdkundebuch und da war so
ein Foto peery am Nordpol genau Robin
der Entdecker des Nordpols genau so habe
ich das gelernt ich weiß nicht ob das
immer noch im Erdkundebuch steht und
irgendwann hat mir Reinhold Messner
erklärt genau Piri war nie am Po nur
richtig und dieses berühmte Foto ja also
Fury war damals auch in im Wettlauf auch
mit Amundsen ich würde sagen den größten
also wenn man alle so nebeneinander hält
muss man sagen der der die allergrößten
entdeckungsleistungen Pionierleistung
und Strapazen auf sich genommen hat und
den hat er damit frustriert dass er
gesagt hat ich bin da und tatsächlich
war er irgendwie nur so ein bisschen in
der Nähe und hatte wenn ich das richtig
Reinhold Messer richtig verstanden hatte
in seinem Haus irgendwo Mittleren Westen
oder so in den USA im Winter in seinem
Garten ein Foto gemacht wie er da und
seine Leute im Anorak diese Fahne
aufpflanzen ja und hatte dieses Foto
irgendwie mitgenommen und hat er das
dann da vom Pool irgendwo in die Welt
gesetzt also so habe ich die Geschichte
in Erinnerung ja ja aber nie da war und
ich glaube bis in den fünf die die echte
Entdeckung des Pols war dann in den 50er
Jahren und die Leute die jetzt erst am
Po waren wussten nicht dass sie die
erste die sind genau
20 Jahren irgendwie ja genau also peery
also es ist eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig klar wer der erste Mensch am
Nordpol war das ist total faszinierend
ja das ist eigentlich eine traurige
Geschichte es hätten wir eigentlich mal
erledigen können Richard aber sag mal
der der Nordpol der Nordpol der wackelt
doch oder ich meinte etwas nicht immer
am selben Ort der der der während
geographische Südpol aber der
geographische fix ist ganz fix naja ist
fix im Sinne von es ist eine eine
bestimmte Position ich bin vor vielen
Jahren mit meinem Freund Armin wird
liebe Grüße an der Stelle und mit Lars
war auch dabei ein Kameramann aus
Düsseldorf das war sehr der Jungs mit
denen bin ich zu Fuß zum Nordpol
gelaufen so auf eigene Faust und das war
doch du der erste
und das war interessant weil sie dann
auch so ein Foto gemacht
ich glaube es wurde eine deutsche Fahne
gemacht
die Flagge von Südtirol aus gibt es doch
bestimmt ne ja klar wie sieht die aus
Weiß und Rot irgend so ein Kreuz drauf
oder ein anderes
ja wir haben sonst sympathischen Adler
da irgendwie drauf naja okay ja genau
aber
weg von Flaggen ja ich ja wir waren dort
am am Pool und es war sehr interessant
weil wir waren ja mit mit GPS unterwegs
und du und wir wussten wirklich nur
anhand des GPS so jetzt 90 Grad Nord
jetzt sind wir da
und wir haben dann dort unser Zelt
aufgeschlagen unser Ostern das war irre
haben dann dort gezeltet und sind dann
über mehrere Tage weil wir auf eine
andere kleine Expedition warten mussten
die parallel zu uns unterwegs war haben
dann dort gezählt und sind in der Zeit
20 30 Kilometer Richtung Grönland
abgetrieben weil unterm Polen eine sehr
starke Strömung ist das heißt du sitzt
auf deine Eisscholle und man treibst du
so langsam treibst du Richtung Grünland
das war spektakulär und irgendwann kam
über Satelliten Telefon der Anruf er
müsste jetzt abbauen weil die die
anderen sind jetzt auch unterwegs war
eine russische Expedition und ihr
solltet die jetzt alle auf 90 Grad Nord
treffen und wir waren ganz froh dass wir
abbauen durften und konnten weil unsere
Schule wurde immer kleiner auf der
wieder gesessen haben und und und schon
damals war interessant zu sehen das war
2003 wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
der Klimaveränderung schon damals war es
schwer den Pool überhaupt zu erreichen
weil sehr viel offenes Wasser da war und
und die die Eisformationen sind
natürlich immer wieder andere die über
den Klang treiben mal ist es viel
offenes Wasser mal ist es ganz dichtes
Packeis und so weiter ja das heißt wenn
du dann in der Zeitung liest der Pool
ist jetzt eisfrei dann ist das auch eine
grenzwertige Information weil je nachdem
wie das die Eisformationen gerade ist ja
dieses Mal
so kann sie ja es ändert sich stündlich
sozusagen und dann sind wir wieder
aufgebrochen zum Pool auch wieder anhand
nur von GPS und traf und dann es war
völlig irre wie so eine Moonraker Szene
aus James Bond irgendwann sagen wir so
kleine schwarze Männchen ja in diesem
weißen weiten nichts das war
unvorstellbar und da kam mir näher ran
und dann schossen die irgendwelche Leute
Rakete in die Luft ich weiß noch ich
sagte zu Army das kann doch nicht sein
dass die jetzt hier er läuft Rakete in
die Luft schießen dass die das
mitgenommen haben ja Gewichte Gewicht
ist alles worum es geht und da kam mir
noch näher an und dann dann die die
Russen die sehr feuchtfröhlich und
einige davon hat noch glaube ich nichts
mehr am Leib sehr betrunken um Zelte
tanzten das war sehr lustig das war das
schönste Besäufnis meines Lebens und
hast du damit gemacht bitte dich also
wenn man schon mal Nordpol ist sagt dann
muss man auch mal nackt
haben wenn ich ums Feuer aber aber es
war es war über lustig weil die hatten
dann so Zelt ja aufgebaut und hatten so
richtig
richtig fettige russische Würstchen da
drin und ist auch einer der grün ist man
dann gerne in der Nähe total gerne und
es ist einer der Gründe warum ich
wirklich die Russen auch so gerne mag
und deswegen finde ich auch so tragisch
was mit diesem Land gerade passiert weil
wenn du in der Kälte unterwegs bist
triffst du immer Russen war Russen
wissen wie das geht wir müssen immer
eine Lösung ja wenn es richtig kalt wird
und ich habe die als wirklich wahnsinnig
warmherzige und sehr zufällig und netten
nette Menschen immer kennengelernt oder
jetzt hatten wir von Piri geredet ne und
an seinem berühmten Fake ich weiß auch
nicht so genau warum das irgendwie mal
enttarnt worden ist das ist ja irgendwie
vor gar nicht so ganz langer Zeit
überhaupt aufgeflogen dass das ein
Schwindel war und und und dem Südpol
diese Geschichte ist ja
hunderttausendmal erzählt ne also der
der zu kurz gekommene Amundsen des
Nordpols der betrogen worden ist genau
der gewinnt der gewinnt gegen Robert
Scott ne den Weg zum Südpol und Scott
kommt dabei um ich habe das Tagebuch von
Scott mal gesehen ich kann mich erinnern
das liegt im British Musical wir haben
die letzte Seite aufgeschlagen diese
Seite ist natürlich Gänsehaut ja hat er
ja damit rein geschrieben ich habe
Bleistift oder sowas also irgendwie 18
Kilometer vor der rettenden Station
gekommen Nahrungsmittel
erfroren und dann hat er der letzte Satz
sein in seinem Tagebuch war gott schütze
unsere Frauen also weiß und dann hat er
weiß durchgestrichen
genau ja unsere Witwen das ist ja aber
die eigentliche ganz große Geschichte
für mich sind eben nicht die beiden
entdeckungsgeschichten sondern das ist
die scheckelten Geschichte von der ich
überhaupt nichts wusste bis ich vor etwa
15 Jahren ein Dokumentarfilm darüber
über die endurance
und über die südsee-expedition von
scheckelten Name hatte ich bis dahin
noch nie gehört und das tolle an diesem
Film ist das er voller authentische
Aufnahmen aus dem Jahre
1915 war die haben sich damals gefilmt
und damit konnte man also diesen
Dokumentarfilm konnte man also das alles
ganz genau nachvollziehen und das war
jetzt irre dass das also 1915 schon
funktioniert hat und das tolle an dieser
schrecklichen Geschichte ist das
scheckelten gar nichts entdeckt hat
[Musik]
nicht die große Leistung also er wollte
immer etwas
dabei gewesen ist dann zurück genau und
dann hat er sich überlegt was kann man
denn jetzt noch entdecken also wo kann
man noch einen draufsetzen und wollte
mit dem Schiff ich glaube so in der
Sommerzeit wenn der wenn der Südpol
nicht ganz irgendwie komplett alles
irgendwie zugefroren ist irgendwie mit
dem Schiff dadurch ne der wollte naja
gut also von einem auf die andere Seite
das geht ja in der Mitte nicht genau am
Südpol ist ja im Gegensatz zum Nordpol
ist ja ist ja eine Landmasse dann
Kontinent der gigantisch groß ist ja
aber wo wollte er da so rum und segeln
oder durch segeln und ich glaube die
Idee war die Antarktis zu durchqueren
tatsächlich das war die Idee das erste
Mensch die Antarktis komplett zu durch
also zu Fuß so wie so wie Reinhold
Messner
okay also das war die Idee also die Idee
die ist in den Hintergrund getreten hier
steht ja bei die ursprüngliche Idee
spielt in der Geschichte überhaupt gar
keine Rolle mehr die fahren mit Ihrem
Schiffen der in eurenster hin und
frieren zu einem viel zu frühen den
Punkt fest genau so und dann drücken die
Eismassen das Schiff immer mehr und mehr
und so bleibt wie nichts anderes übrig
als das Schiff zu verlassen genau ja und
alles was da an Bord ist schleppen sie
darunter und gucken Seelen ruhig zu wie
das Schiff dann total zerquetscht wird
deine rückreiseversicherung ja werde
damit ein Buch weißt du du kommst hier
nicht mehr weg ja nie wieder ja so das
nächste ist es wird wärmer und die
Landmasse auf die sie sich da geflüchtet
haben war also offensichtlich kein
Festland sondern auch irgendwo drei
Preis ja und dieses Eis wird schmilzt
genau und du sitzt dann auf einer
Eisscholle ewig auf eine Eisscholle du
hast überhaupt nichts zu tun du bist
ziemlich sicher du wirst hier nicht
gefunden
du kommst aber auch nicht weg du hast ja
kein Schiff ja das ist die
Ausgangsposition so und dann wartest du
und wartest du und wartest du eigentlich
auf was denn eigentlich das durch ein
riesen Zufall jemand vorbeikommt kann
doch keiner vorbeikommen ist doch alles
so festgefroren und so weiter ne aber
irgendwann ist deine Eisscholle
geschmolzen oder wirst die oder so und
dann sind die mit dem Rettungsboot Weg
genau so und dann sind die Rettungsboot
weg und dass man 27 man glaube ich 27
Mann und landen ja irgendwann ist Land
in Sicht genau ganz große Freude ja weil
strapaziöse Überfahrt wahnsinniges
Wetter Schneestürme das kann man sich
eigentlich kaum vorstellen die kommen da
an und so wie wie Kolumbus in in El
Salvador ne also wahnsinnig glücklich
stellen aber fest dass sie nicht auf dem
südamerikanischen Festland sind sondern
auf einer gottverlassene Insel
quellephant Island wahrscheinlich so
genannt wegen der Seeelefanten die da
hinkommen und bis auf Robben gibt es da
nichts einfach nur eine Geröllhalde
genau so und da bleiben sie wieder schön
lange und wissen auch hier werden sie
nicht gefunden und wahrscheinlich sind
Robben was es ja gerade erzählt
vitaminreich und so weiter deren Bild
und so du kannst also von Robben
überleben das geht wohl soll nicht gut
schmecken sagt man so aber ist
vielleicht nicht die autofrage gewesen
ja
dein Leben lang einfach nur ja Robben zu
erschlagen zu essen und ansonsten darum
zu hängen auf diese auf Elefant Island
und da irgendwann lang war zu kriegen
und zu sterben genau so also beschließt
checkelten mit einem ich meine es wäre
nur einer gewesen ich weiß nicht genau
ja companion da wegzufahren und zu wagen
mit dem Schiff eine 1000 500 km lange
Reise anzutreten um das wieder
amerikanische Festland zu erreichen
so und jetzt muss man sich vorstellen
die hatten ich weiß dass der hieß es
irgendwie mal in diesem Bericht erzählt
ist und Alter Seemann wie man sich die
Überfahrt vorstellen kann es gab
irgendwie noch so Reste von
Schiffszwieback weil der Robben konnte
so irgendwie nicht mitnehmen auf dem
Boot und dann meinte er meinte der
irgendwie sie haben morgens dran
gerochen ja
mittags dran gesaugt abends haben sie
ihn gegessen ja ich kann es mir
vorstellen und dann mit einem 7 Meter
langen Boot ich meine es werden nur zwei
Personen gewesen er wäre dann äh dahin
so und die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
dieses Festland erreichen würdest du
total gering ja und gegen jede jede
Wahrscheinlichkeit schaffen sie es und
landen da und so auch da wo sie hin
wollten und auf der anderen Seite und
eine Forschungsstation oder so
und jetzt muss ich immer an den Seewolf
denken
Sie diese Verfilmung von Seewolf vor
Augen hast ja Kartoffeln mit der
Kartoffel genau mit der berühmten
Kartoffel genau und der heißt der dritte
Teil das Land der kleinen zwei
und da wird der Seewolf ausgesetzt und
haben viel von beiden hatte versucht zu
fliehen von dem Boot und die beiden sind
irgendwie eine Lebensgemeinschaft eine
Notgemeinschaft die zwei und schlagen
sich dadurch so menschenleeres Gebiet
durch
und da kommt diese Situation dass
natürlich Wolf Larsen der Seewolf
Raimund Harmsdorf körperlich völlig
überlegen und so weiter vorangeht und
Humphrey von beiden verknackt sich den
Fuß ja und bleibt da liegen ja und dann
heißt es über über den Seewolf und der
ging einfach weiter ohne sich auch nur
ein einziges mal umzudrehen und der
nächste Satz ist er hatte es so
eingerichtet dass alle Munitionen und
die Gewehre sich in seinem Rucksack
befanden er hat also eigentlich gar
keine Chance mehr dazu überleben
versucht Fische zu fangen schafft das
nicht ist Mose und krabbelt auf allen
Vieren vorwärts um diese
Forschungsstation zu erreichen und so
ähnlich stelle ich mir das vor mit
scheckelten und sein Kumpel da ankam
völlig fertig ja total hier nichts
nichts zu essen mehr gehabt unsere
entkräftet und müssen über einen Berg
rüber
weil auf der anderen Seite des Berges
liegt diese Forschungsstation und dann
krabbeln die auf allen Vieren diesen
Berg hoch und auf der anderen Seite
lassen sie sich einfach nur runterholen
ja weiß ich jetzt schon fertig
und dann will er natürlich unbedingt
eine Expedition machen nach Elephant
Island um seine Leute zu holen genau und
das Problem ist dass die Wetterlage das
nicht zulässt und dann bleibt er ewig da
bis dieses Expeditionsschiff kommt was
umgekehrt wieder bedeutet dass die Leute
auf Elephant Island alle davon
ausgegangen sind dass er natürlich
tun weil die wussten dieser Mann der der
als charismatische Persönlichkeit
geschildert wird
überhaupt ja genau dass der natürlich
sofort seine Leute retten würden
irgendwann hat er dann diese Expedition
gemacht kommt da nach Elephant Island
alle seine Leute leben da auch noch ja
und die fallen natürlich aus einem
Wolken setzen Erscheinung die können
sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass er
noch lebt und hier sind davon
ausgegangen die verbringen den Rest
ihrer Tage und jetzt kommt die richtige
filmpointe dieser ganzen Geschichte die
werden dann gerettet hurra alles ist
großartig alle freuen sich und dann
fahren Sie zurück nach England
und dann kommen sie zurück nach England
und die ich meine die hatten ja nichts
entdeckt diese irrsinnige Leistung
bestand im überleben also gegen jede
Wahrscheinlichkeit
einer ist nicht gekommen und das ist die
spektakuläre Leistung ja vorstellbar
jetzt kommen die nach England und
erwarten natürlich ja dass jeder diese
Geschichte hören will ne und das jeder
dass sie natürlich auch große Helden
sind weil dieses überlebensleistungen
große Heldentat war es war aber der
erste Weltkrieg ausgebrochen das Land
hatte jetzt ganz andere Helden das hatte
ganz andere Sorgen und kein Mensch
interessierte sich mehr für Polar
Entdecker das Thema war sowas von out
das verrückt und ein großer Teil seiner
Leute die ja jung gewesen sind wurden
sofort eingezogen und die meisten davon
sind im Ersten Weltkrieg gefallen ist
das bitte die Pointe könnte ich nicht ja
du überlebt hast diese diese irrsinnig
Existenz
was dazu gehört und so weiter ja und du
bist das bitte kommst dann in so einem
blöden Schützengraben
ich ich kennst die Geschichte von Nansen
ne Friedrich aufeinander ist im Grunde
das gleiche immer die die erste große
Reise von Nansen zum zum Nordpol das war
ja auch so ein
unvorstellbares Ding was die gemacht
haben dir die haben sich dieses Schiff
gebaut die Farben das war das Schiff mit
der mit dem später die Frame war das
Schiff mit dem später haben uns zum
Südpol gereist ist ja und die sind
Richtung Nordpol gezogen und die Idee
war wir lassen uns einfach und nördlich
von Sibirien im Parkhaus einfriert
einschließen und nannten waren genialer
Navigator und die haben sich
ausgerechnet durch die Strömung wird uns
irgendwann dieses Pack als einfach wie
von selbst wie von Geisterhand über 90
Grad Nord über den Nordpol drüber
treiben und wir sitzen da und spielen
bisschen Karten und nebenbei erobern wir
in Nordpol das war die Idee
Prozent der Idee waren realistisch die
die sind erstaunlich es ist total
interessant ich mal die diese verrückte
Kurve anzugucken es ist alles genau
nachvollzogen worden wie die Fragen
damals mit Nansen das ging ja aber lange
Zeit
wie die da langsam Richtung Norden
getrieben sind und erstaunlich daran
gekommen sind aber irgendwann so ein
richtiger Zickzack-Kurs und irgendwann
war aber klar die werden den Nordpol
nicht treffen wird nicht funktionieren
und das war der Moment in dem Nansen
dann beschlossen hat ihr treibt jetzt
einfach weiter und erst mit Johannsen
enger Gefährte und ein paar Hunden haben
die beiden sich alleine auf den Weg
gemacht zum Nordpol ohne zu wissen
müsste mal vorstellen du verlässt dieses
Schiff dass deine Lebensversicherung ist
und sie ist einfach los mit einem
Schlitten und einem treuen Gefährten in
der Hoffnung irgendwann den Pool zu
erreichen und wie wir zurückkommen
werden wir sehen werden wir dann schon
irgendwie organisieren es ist Wahnsinn
und die waren damals sehr sehr nah dran
am Pool ich glaube 88 Grad und ein paar
zerquetschte ich glaube 88 Grad und 60
Minuten sowas habe ich im Kopf also sehr
sehr nah dran haben dann aber gemerkt
wenn wir jetzt weitergehen und das ist
halt die Generalität von Nansen gewesen
der dann später auch als Politiker
weltberühmt wurde Nobelpreis bekommen
hat und so weiter
wenn wir das machen dann kommen wir um
und dann den Mut auch zu haben
umzudrehen und da da ging es nur noch
ums nackte Überleben die haben sich
danach Süden irgendwie durchgeschlagen
und kamen dann raus auf so einem
Archipel der der liegt östlich von von
Spitzbergen auch so eine Inselgruppe
ähnlich wie Spitzbergen aber völlig
unbewohnt Franz Josef Land sibirische
Aktes und überwintern dann und
überstehen diese unfassbar kalte
dunklere harte Polar nach Monate lang
schwarz und Nacht vor Augen ja soweit im
Norden der dauert das endlos lange
überwintern in so einem kleinen Loch
wo sie dann mit mit irgendwelchen
treibhölzern und und der Haut von
Walrossen bauen sie sich so eine
Notunterkunft zu uns hält werden bedroht
von Eisbären und so weiter ist eine irre
Geschichte und überstehen das alles und
als das früher kommt bauen sie sich so
aus dem Schlitten irgendwie so ein
Schiffs und Kahn und versuchen über
diese Inselgruppe sich immer weiter nach
Süden durchzuschlagen und kommen dann
raus kam Flora ich war da mal an diesem
das kannst Du heute noch sehen an diesem
dieser Ort wo die gelegen haben ist wie
wie ein kaltes Grab da drin haben die
überwinter diese beiden und und haben
das so gut gemacht dass sie sogar
Gewicht zugenommen haben in der Zeit
weil sie sehr erfolgreich rumgejagt
haben und Walrosse und so weiter und und
ziehen dann im Frühjahr weiter kommen
Kampf Flora raus und sind dann dort
unterwegs das sozusagen der der
südlichsten Punkte die dieser
Inselgruppe und zwar die Frage wie
kommen wir jetzt hier weg
und es war klar dass die dort sein
könnten und plötzlich stoßen sie am
Strand auf einen Engländer der von
seinem Schiff runterkommt Jackson der
diesem Strand entlang geht Entdecker ja
alle waren damals Entdecker die sich
leisten konnten auch eine Frage des
Geldes und der stößt auf einen völlig
verwilderten verrußten Typen und der
guckt ihn an und sagt sind sie Nansen
und dann sagt ja ich bin Hansen irre und
nimmt die dann mit und
bringt die zurück nach Norwegen und es
stellt sich raus die Männer von der Farm
das stimmt die kommen entweder wenig
später oder wenig vorher aber fast zum
selben Zeitpunkt in Nord Norwegen an
eine ehrliche Geschichte eine der großen
Heldengeschichten wenn du einen weltweit
also Nacht
[Musik]
gelesen nee ich habe das nicht gelesen
ich liebe dieses Buch ist ein
großartiges Buch ja irre könnte eine
stundenlang weitermachen
wir sind wir sind am Ende ja also mir
ist mittlerweile richtig kalt geworden
genau
aber ist das nicht schön wie man ihn im
Kopf verreisen kann das ist so wunderbar
und deswegen andere heller hatte Recht
die wahren Abenteuer sind im Kopf ohne
jeden Zweifel ja also die Welt der
Fantasie ist das Reich aus dem man nicht
vertrieben werden kann
geklaut aber ich weiß nicht von wem gut
geklaut Richard danke dir hat Spaß
tschüss ciao ciao ciao
eine Produktion von zwei und Pots bei
OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]